سانطرح من الشمال وحينما نشير الى الشمال
لعل تطوراته المتلاحقه هي التي فرضت وضعه
في صدره هذا العرض حيث اشارت كانت هناك
عمليه استهداف مكثفه للقوات الاسرائيليه
او للغارات الاسرائيليه على اكثر من موقع
لكن الجديد هو هذه الاشتباكات التي تخوضها
المقاومه على اكثر من محور خصوصا هنا في
الشمال الغربي لمدينه غزه خصوصا الكرامه
وايضا الشيخ رضوان ولكن ايضا هنا في شرق
التفاح ولكن ايضا في جباليه بالنسبه
لتطورات في الكرامه القسام اعلنت عن كمين
كمين لقوه داخل منزل في منطقه الكرامه
وقالت بانها استهدفتهم بقذائف الياسين في
هذه المنطقه اضافه الى استهدافها ايضا
لدبابه ميركافا في نفس الموقع لكن التطور
الاخر هو استهداف ايضا مجموعه من الاليات
هنا في تخوم الشيخ رضوان محور غربي اذا
تشتبك فيه المقاومه مع القوات الاسرائيليه
لكن اللافت ايضا هو هذه الاشتباكات التي
وقعت ايضا في شرق جباليا من خلال استهداف
ايضا ناقله جند وغير بعيد ايضا هنا شرق
التفاح وتحديدا في جبل الريس قالت القسام
بانها
استهدفت استهدفت ايضا ناقله جند هندسيه
كما قالت في هذه في هذا المحور اذا لاحظوا
كيف تلتهب نوعا ما هذه المساحات من قطاع
غزه بعد ان كان هناك حديث كبير عن منطقه
الشمال والحديث ايضا اعاده انتشار الجيش
الاسرائيلي خصوصا في هذه المناطق لو ننتقل
سريعا الى المنطقه الوسطى لعل البارس فيها
هو هذه التطورات خصوصا في مخيم المغازي
وحينما نذكر مخيم المغازي نشير الى ان
القسام كانت اشارت الى استهداف ست دبابات
من نوع ميركافا وتدميرها تدميرا كليا
اضافه الى ايضا استهدافها لنقله جونده
تحدثت ايضا القسام في نفس المكان في
المغازي عن عمليه مزدوجه مع سرايا القدس
واستهداف ايضا لمركبات اسرائيليه ياتي ذلك
بينما استمرت عمليه القصف لمختلف المحاور
او النقاط الاربع ان صح القاو التي نتحدث
عنها دوما مخيم البريج نصيرات الزويده
اضافه الى المغازي وكان هناك ايضا قصف على
دير البلاح ربما نختم بالجبهه الثالثه
والاخيره وهي الجبهه الجنوبيه اللافت في
هذه الجبهه جبهه خان يونس هو عمليه القصف
بالخصوص للمناطق الغربيه لمدينه خان يونس
ولكن ايضا المناطق الوسطى كان هناك حديث
عن اشتباكات خصوصا في وسط خان يونس في
منطقه البلد في المحطه في الكتيبه ولكن
ايضا
القسام كتائب القسام ومق قتلوها اشتبكوا
مع قوه اسرائيليه في محيط مستشفى ناصر
القسام ايضا اعلنت عن استهداف اليات
عسكريه في الجهه الجنوبيه من خان يونس
وتحديدا في معا تحدثت عن اشتباكات من
المصافه الصفر ولكن ايضا سريا القدس ايضا
اعلنت عن استهداف مقر للقياده العسكريه
وذلك امام كليه العلوم والتكنولوجيا في
جنوب خانيونس